hi my name is Mai Cory I am retired from
Boeing and I'm interested in some topics
in quantum physics says specifically
Bell's Theorem this talk is a
continuation of last year's talk and F
dative research had done in the last
year thank you very much my name is
Michael Rhee and I am retired I used to
work for Boeing and I used to give talks
on what I worked on at Boeing now I have
a hobby and that hobby is trying to
understand some nice physics fun things
I wanted to do always when I was an
engineer but didn't have the time so I
am a complete not a complete novice but
I'm not a professional physicist never
was I was an engineer but anyway these
topics interest me and in particular I'm
interested in quantum physics and the
foundations of quantum physics in
particular Bell's Theorem which is all
interested to me for a long time
and last year I gave a talk on this some
of you may have been here pull up your
hand if you heard my talk last year
anybody okay all right so this won't be
too much of a repeat then but anyway
I've done some work since then that I
would like to report and Mathematica has
been extremely helpful and being able to
do stuff like you know with pencil and
paper it would have been impossible to
get to this point so it's really
wonderful to have a tool like this to
get things better understood so let's
see if there we go I know she's a
touchpad here usually I use the mouse so
so I'm going to tell you what this talk
is about and not about it's not going to
be about all this stuff only one small
part of it mainly down here where we
have the aspect experiment and we're
trying to understand good models for the
aspect experiment I'm not going to talk
about the EPR paper or
their original hadouken experiment where
I'm standing was worried about quantum
theory getting away from what he thought
physics should be it should be about
real stuff out there that you do
experiments and you can determine what
that stuff is he didn't like the idea
that you the observer was starting to
have have a role that it shouldn't have
and things didn't appear until the
observer looked at it he didn't like
that
he and board debated that for years and
years even before the paper and then
after the paper and then it kind of went
into a limbo kind of thing and then in
1964 Bell took Einsteins argument of the
EPR argument and kind of turned it on
its head and said if I assume the things
that Einstein assumed I can come up with
an inequality which is a false avaiable
by experiment the technology had caught
up and he came up with a falsifiable
statement that experiment could decide
was true or false he had a simple
inequality which is illustrated in this
box at the lower right hand corner and
then several experiments were done
before 1982 but that kind of the
clincher was the 1982 one which kind of
confirmed what Bell said basically if
you assume locality and reality in some
sense then you get countered you get a
model that doesn't have is unable to
make predictions that quantum mechanics
can make some predictions that quantum
mechanics can make and this led to more
experiments I think in 2015 there was
the final experiment to end all the
loopholes the detection loophole the
fair sampling theorem loophole hope the
fair sampling loophole and all these
kind of loopholes that statisticians and
physicists had worried about and then
there's been all kinds of debate there's
been debates about what Bell actually
proved what Einstein actually said it
goes on and on and on you get all these
different formulations and
interpretations the
multi-universe interpretation of quantum
physics the pilot-wave theory of debris
bomb of quantum physics and the debate
the the the the growth of ideas and
formulations keeps going to this day I
mean it's amazing how many papers come
out every year that cite bells paper
thousands of them so my job and this
might my goal in in doing this project
was to kind of understand what Bell
actually said in terms of what does what
did he assume mathematically that
locality meant what did he assume
mathematically that reality meant and
does that have anything to do with our
common sense everyday concept of those
those ideas of those words so that's
what I was trying to get to and first of
all let me just briefly say how the
aspect experiment is done this is just a
abstract picture the plus ones and minus
ones coming out as as results so you see
outcomes really numbers involving
Planck's constant and PI but you can
since there's only two outcomes you can
assume they're plus and minus one if you
rescale everything so everything in this
paper will be plus or minus one so just
assume all the physics is rescaled
so Alice is at one laboratory bob is at
another laboratory there's there they're
separated by a huge distance and they
can only do things in their own
laboratory they can't see what's going
on and the other one and Alice has to
measurement angles that the Sailor
measuring photon polarizations the
polarization of photons entangled photon
pair one of the pair goes to Alice the
other pair goes to Bob and Alice does a
measurement on her part and Bob doesn't
measurement on his part at different
angles of their choices and Alice
doesn't know Bob's angles and Bob
doesn't know Alice's choice of angles
then he then you get plus or minus one
coming out of Alice's experiment out of
Bob's experience they go to a
coincidence monitor don't ask me how
that happens at the moment because
they're separated by a lot
dissonance that's another issue for
another day but let's assume that you
can compare those and you get either
perfect correlation plus plus minus
minus or at perfect and a correlation
plus minus or minus plus then you put
them into bins according to which choice
of angle settings are made either a for
Bob or a prime for Bob I'm sorry a for
Alice or a prime for Alice B for Bob or
B prime for a Bob so you have four bins
you add up all the plus ones and all the
minus ones and then you do a correlation
estimate by subtracting the the number
of minus ones in each bin from the
number of plus ones and putting it over
the sum of all the samples and then that
becomes a correlation estimate and then
you do certain things with that court
with those correlations which I'm going
to explain in a moment first of all you
might have a an example set of outcomes
as follows you have a large number of
capital n trials I've shown 10 here
notice there's only one plus or minus
one in each row that means they can only
have one setting at a time either a B a
B prime B prime B or a PB prime B prime
there's no more than one row 1 1 or
minus 1 per row so in each column you
add up all the ones and all the plus
ones all the minus ones for example in
the first column n 1 plus and N 1 minus
similarly for the other columns and then
you compute the correlations as I
explained before the difference between
the pluses and the minuses over the sum
of the pluses and minuses each column
and then you compute what's called what
I'm going to call an S function in an
aspects description of his experiments
he called it s he took the correlations
he added them up but put one minus sign
in there in all the four possible ways
so there's four possible s functions so
these become estimates of those s
functions S one had s 2 has to be hat in
this four hat those are crucial is a
crucial to the difference between what
quantum mechanics can predict and what a
real or local model can predict
or can't predict so keep in mind those s
functions I'll tell you what they are
later on too so don't worry about that
but in any case it turns out that this
is a little bit of words I just said oh
I didn't say it quite as detailed as
this but it turns out that the s
functions by bells assumptions can only
his in equality says these can only be
between no more than two and no less
than minus two whereas quantum mechanics
predicts that there are some situations
where you can get as low as minus two
times the square root of two and as high
as plus two times the square root of two
and a bell real or local model cannot do
that so something's going on here you
have two Bell said you got to pick two
out of three you can have realism you
have locality you can have quantum
mechanics pick two can only have two
you're gonna have to give up one of them
and that's the essence of Bell's Theorem
because of a simple inequality having to
do with probability and I wanted to
understand exactly what those
assumptions were made were by the way
I'm going to use not Bell's original
theorem but but a paper that came later
in 1969 clauser horn Simoni and Holt
that's where she H s H comes from they
had a generalization of bells inequality
so my approach in and doing this was to
define or to assume a set of random
variables a is capital A's Alice's
outcome capital B Bob calm D of capital
a is Alice's detector setting D of
capital B is Bob's detector setting and
the deltas are the probabilities of the
four different combinations of detector
settings to for Alice to for Bob and
this is the key to though my whole
starting point in trying to understand
it I deposited a generic model sixteen
possible outcomes for the for random
variables which can each take plus one
or minus one in a PMF
probability mass function where the
gamma k's demo1 through gamma 16 or
conditional probabilities that given
that detector setting you get that
outcome and the deltas of course are the
the probabilities of the detector
settings to begin with so this is a
conditional probability times the
detector setting probability and so all
the 16 numbers if you think about it add
up to 1 and they're non-negative and add
up to 1 so it's a probability mass
function given the constraints on the
right all right now
oops sorry yep sorry next one
okay locality what did what what are the
definitions of locality that's the
problem with the understanding Bell's
Theorem is and the whole debate about it
is there's at least four different
definitions of locality and that's why I
wanted to straighten all this out you've
got remote context independence that
means that Alice's outcome only depends
on her on her detector setting not on
Bob's detector setting that's the first
one our CI the second one instead
similarly for Bob the sickle and remote
outcome independence that means that
Alice's outcome does not depend on Bob's
outcome given the two detector settings
similarly for Bob
that's ROI local causality is even
stronger
it says Alice's outcome as a condition
on Bob's outcome and the two detector
settings ends up being the same exactly
the same as a low probability of Alice's
outcome given her setting you can throw
away Bob's outcome you can throw away
Bob's detector setting that probability
doesn't depend on those two things
that's a really strong independence and
then the last one the really strong one
well it turns out to be equivalent to
local causality this kind of a
independent a conditional independence
statement the probability of Alice and
Bob joint probability of Alice and Bob's
outcomes given their detector settings
was equal to the conditional probability
Alice has given her detector setting
times probability of Bob's outcome given
his detector city
it's kind of a conditional independence
sort of thing so you've got those four
definitions of locality they're kind of
floating around you got a straight now
and that's what I tried to do and this
been in this presentation and the paper
I've written on this topic and reality
has to do with the idea that what
Einstein says if he was telling me
quantum physics is right something's
going on here there has to be something
sent to Alice and something sent to Bob
hidden variables like two outcomes a1
and a2 sent to Alice and he and she gets
a one if she chooses her first detector
setting gets a two if she chooses a
second detector setting similarly for
Bob and that's what's really going on
that's what Einstein would like to think
and then and then that leads to I shown
my paper which isn't published I'm
trying to get it published if anybody
wants to give me help on that I'd
appreciate it if you start with the a1
a2 b1 b2 and assume of Row 1 through 16
probability distribution that turns into
the a B da DB format on the right on the
left is what you know Bell actually in
cause there'll CH SH actually assumed on
the right is my form reformulations of
that and I've not seen this three
formulation on the right anywhere this
is kind of new as far as I'm concerned I
haven't seen that kind of thing in any
papers but it's equivalent to the one on
the left just in a different different
arrangement so remember that's that's
what reality means and in the CH SH or
the Bell assumption of what reality
means just that it's just mathematics
that's all it is so now you have I
discuss five main modeling types so I
can compare how each one performs in
terms of the S function output and
there's five conditional probabilities
notice I've dropped the detector
settings these are just the gammas for
the generic for example the fourth
column over the generic model or maximal
model you'll see
I call it either one in a moment the
gamma caves can be anything although
four of them have to add up each their
sets of four that have to add up to one
that total column will head up to four
each column will add up to four in each
case there's sixteen sixteen output
loops what happened here not very good
with the touchpad there we go
okay and then the constraints at the
bottom are these you know mm-hmm the
fifth column over the quantum mechanics
are just the predictions of the standard
Hilbert space theory except I will not
accept but I also have a constraint that
the last three angles difference angle
measurement different signals have to
sum up to the first one and I'll show
you why that is in a minute the the next
column over are the Bell real
conditional probabilities those wrote
case have to add up to 1 and then
they'll bell local is the next of the
last column where the alpha k's are
alice's conditional probabilities the
beta cases are bobs conditional
probabilities and the overall joint
conditional probability is just the
product of those two it's exactly what
locality means and then the last column
is already called a trivial model it
just says everything is 1/4 a completely
uniform distribution not a very
interesting model but it kind of
indicates the minimum just like the
generic models the maximum and the
reason for the the angle measurement
angle things nice Teta 1 equals theta 2
plus theta 3 plus theta 4 just look at
this diagram you have Alice's angles a
and a prime Bob's angles being B Prime
and the the difference angles and by the
way in quantum theory the outcomes of
the measurements only depend on the
difference between the angles that's why
you define the Thetas and you notice in
this particular picture of theta ones
the sum of the other three now that
could be a different arrangement but you
can always make it look like this so
we'll just assume that then the
correlations for each of the model their
conditional correlations of products
Alice's measurement times Bob I mean
outcome times Bob's outcome
times B which will always be plus or
minus one based on four different
detector setting combinations so you
have four different populations
correlations you can compute and this is
the table of what they look like
you have the generic ones the first
column then the QM ones which are
cosines of two times the difference
angles in each case the Bell real ones
which are plus/minus sums of all the row
case and then about locals are that
interesting products of the Bob's and
Alice's conditional probability minimal
is trivial they're all zero because it's
uniform there's no correlation at all
and then the CHS inequalities clouds are
horn Simonian whole to both the paper in
69 says that those equality say that all
four of the S functions have to be
between minus two and two that's that
paper you can also read it in the class
in any textbook on quantum theory I'm
gonna pick one book that I know the
author of that's what the CHS inequality
looks like then you get Bell's Theorem
in a nutshell compute all the S
functions compute their maximum ends
first column Q M the maximum enter + - +
- + - x squared - down the bottom read
the bottom row the bottom row the
maximum in you know 2 times square root
2 and QM Bell real and bill local plus 2
and minus 2 what that tells you is that
the S functions you get from assuming
locality reality cannot cannot predict
cannot recreate all of the predictions
of quantum mechanics some of them but
not all the extreme values of the
quantum mechanics ones are higher than
the Bell real or bell local ones that's
essentially what Bell's Theorem is
telling you if you assume reality or
locality as a picture version of this I
like a lot based on the angles the Green
Square is the limit of the Bell
predictions which is - that's at a
height of the belt the Green Square is a
height of 2
this the very curvy yellow surface
that's the s-1 function by the way this
is all the s1 as a function of the
measurement angles the yellow surface is
the Q quantity can accesing now it's
mostly below the square so they agree
down there or they could agree but above
that they can't possibly agree and the
example that's usually cited in the
literature the notorious angles of 22
and 1/2 degrees 22 and 1/2 degrees 22
and 1/2 degrees is sixty seven point
five degrees is the purple dot at the
top that's where the Bell I mean the
quantum mechanics s one function reaches
to the value of two times the square
root of two and that can't possibly done
be done by a Bell real model so that's
another way to look at Bell's Theorem
pictorially and here's the summary of
the results from the work I did I mean
some of this is old news but some of it
by my definitions is kind of interesting
in a different way of looking at things
all Bell local model instances these
these are instances these are made to be
meant to be model instance you put in
actual numbers the set of all such
models for Bell local is a strict
strictly contained within the Bell real
models QM intersects the Bell real
models they're in a non empty subset an
infinite subset but only Bell local the
only Qi model that's also Bell local is
just one the trivial model the one with
zero correlations which is not very
interesting of course so it doesn't mean
much and then there's the deterministic
model types and this is something new I
haven't seen anywhere I've just I was
able to determine there's there's all
these the deterministic well first of
all it's deterministic deterministic
means that all the parameters in that
table I showed you at the beginning like
the gamma case or the ROE case they all
have to be 0 or 1 it can't be anything
in between just 0 or 1 what that means
it makes the the correlations all plus
or minus 1
that is everything is either perfectly
correlated or perfectly anti-correlated
this is what Einstein was looking for
way back in 1935 he said what happened
to determinism what happened to being
able to tell something's really there
that I can really tell you what it is
and that's why he proposed originally a
deterministic kind of he said he said
the random are the hidden variables
should be deterministic so that's why
everybody considers those as well and in
my situation I have the I can decide or
you can divide them up into four
different types the the inside type one
there's only sixteen instances of those
and those are all Bell real and Bell
local all the other three are not either
Bell real or Bell local yet two of them
satis to satisfy the CHS inequalities
that is they they don't they can't
predict all of the predictions or
recreate all predictions or quantum
theory which is kind of interesting in
other words it's not the the satisfying
that the CHS inequalities is is the
necessary condition but not sufficient
for this oh I just round time didn't I
so what should I say here I guess that's
well oh I want to show you one last
thing and now okay this is my favorite
part of the things is able to do because
this finally helped me understand all
the relationships between all of the
concepts all the models all of the
conditions that people talk about in the
in the quantum theory paper or the
foundational quantum theory papers on
Bell real and Bell local and all that
Bell's Theorem all of those things is
able to put together in this chart and
show how they're all related to each
other so you'll see for example Bell
local feeds into Bell real every Bell
local models built Bell real quantum
mechanics in Bell real both feed into
remote context independence which is
very interesting they're supposed to be
different quantum mechanics is touted as
non-local but
goes right into remote context
independence which is a local concept
just like though real does and notice
that all the boxes outlined in red are
all the all the types of models or
conditions that satisfy the CH SH
inequalities that that is cannot
recreate the predictions of all the
predictions of quantum mechanics so
since I ran out of time I'd better leave
it at that
thank you very much
[Applause]